[Music]
hey true believers I'm Lorraine and this
is the Marvel minute bringing you 60
seconds of Marvel news and we've got a
lot to cover today so let's get right
into it first we have huge news for you
all at home you saw it in theaters and
now you can own it forever Marvel
Studios Black Panther comes home with
its digital release tomorrow followed by
the blu-ray and DVD release on May 15th
now you can relive the world of Wakanda
right from your couch or wherever you
happen to be moving on to some other
favorite heroes Marvel's Luke Cage
season 2 is gonna be here before you
know it but if you can't wait new season
2 art was just released this morning
overall marvel calm and you can check
out the brand-new trailer while you're
over there
this season Luke finds he has become a
celebrity in Harlem but that means new
threats and a new reputation season 2
premieres June 22nd on Netflix over on
Marvel's agents of shield this week the
penultimate episode is here and it's all
leading up to the epic season finale Jay
Z's future as the destroyer of worlds
could take a critical change and you're
not gonna want to miss it
check it out this Friday 9:00 8:00
central on ABC and finally Marvel Puzzle
Quest has unveiled a new character black
widow inspired by Marvel's Avengers
infinity war is now playable in the game
she's geared up and ready to go and a
total badass oh go ahead and assemble
her alongside your epic team of
superheroes and that's all the time we
have for this week see you next time on
the Marvel minute